l'actualité c'est peut-être aussi
aujourd'hui lily passion une heure et
demie de spectacle qui met face à face
barbara et depardieu c'est un conte
musical pensé écrit conçu par la
chanteuse qui raconte l'histoire d'amour
d'une femme en noir vous l'avez compris
et d'un assassin nicole denis langlois a
assisté hier soir à la première de cette
représentation
elles chantent ils tuent ils s'aiment et
pour ce couple de passion ils sont tous
venus au rendez-vous des ministres en
place et les gens du métier des amis
et puis elisabeth émue pour gérard
entendre une dernière fois la voix qui
chante chaud et
landais
le temps me contre une fois triés pour
une fois est morte rallye j'y croyais
moi ma mission date afin d'y avec
agences je suis venu ma plus belle
histoire d'amour est beau
une déclaration d'amour que barbara
adresse au public
retrouvez un pari périlleux gagner ce
soir est commencé depuis longtemps
depuis top 5 ans
c'est ce travail effacer la complicité
de barbara et c'est cette assiduité
cette rigueur ces contraintes
quand il est fan de tous les instants
qui fait que ce qu'on existe maintenant
c'est magique
mini ce soir
la passion pour
voilà la qualité de ce mardi c'est tout